welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today and I
will also be with you tomorrow you know
a lot has been said recently about guns
in the United States obviously for very
good reasons there's a huge movement
we've got to get some kind of gun
control but there's there's another
issue related to that that we absolutely
also have to discuss and it is the fact
that right now the United States
Department of Defense the United States
military is spending money at such an
alarming rate that you have to wonder
what is on the horizon according to a
recent report Lockheed Martin in 2017
got thirty five point two billion
dollars from the US Defense Department
they accounted that money to Lockheed
Martin from the Defense Department
accounted for 70 percent of the
company's total sales in 2017 that
thirty five billion dollars is more than
the United States funded NASA with last
year it's the same as the GDP of Bolivia
according to reports and that's how much
we spent on just one defense contractor
to buy their fighter jets Boeing not too
far behind them got twenty six point
five billion in 2016 and excuse me the
Lockheed Martin money was 2016 not 2017
but look we are spending tens of
billions of dollars per defense
contractor right now we just upped the
military budget for this coming year
more billions upon billions upon
billions to feed this disgusting war
machine that we have built as a country
but this 35 billion to Lockheed Martin
alone not even including the twenty six
billion the Boeing
this is disgusting for the United States
for many many reasons first and foremost
because we've been told a little too
often in the last year that as a country
we simply can't afford something as as
monumental as universal health care we
can't afford debt-free college we can't
afford to forgive student loans anymore
why well for one because we've got to
get tax cuts to our wealthy donors but
two because these poor defense
contractors are just starving for our
money I think about that if we just took
only the money that we gave to Lockheed
and Boeing in a single year which is
more than sixty billion dollars because
that's a 35-point to two Lockheed is
actually a little bit lower than usual
their average is about 38 billion a year
so anyway just those two Lockheed and
Boeing 60 billion a year how many
doctors visits could that buy for
American citizens how many prescriptions
could that fill how many cancer
screenings could that fund how many
students could we send to college how
many school lunches could we buy for
starving American children how many
homes could we build for the homeless I
mean the possibilities of what we could
do with this money are endless but
instead we're buying tanks
we're buying long-range missiles that
was part of this thirty-five billion
dollars that Lockheed got was because
we're currently having several different
companies develop new long-range
missiles and it's basically a bidding
war we're giving each company that makes
these things some money to develop one
and whoever makes the best one is going
to get the main contract to get billions
upon billions more according to the
Washington Post so essentially we're
having a bidding war right now to see
who can make the bomb that goes the
farthest and blows up the most things
and then whoever gets that whoever makes
it whoever creates it you're gonna get a
few extra billion dollars because
congratulations you won the American
contest of death because let's be honest
that's what this is that's what is
happening here we are so invested the
military complex here in the United
States is so invested in destroying as
much as possible that the government
doesn't care what they're blowing money
on meanwhile too many kids in this
country go each day without enough to
eat they're not getting proper nutrition
we have US military veterans and other
American citizens that sleep on the
streets each night they don't know where
their next meal is going to come from
they don't have a roof over their head
if it gets too cold they freeze to death
if it gets too hot they can die from
dehydration and yet we're dumping tens
of billions of dollars into each
individual defense contractor and that's
what's disgusting here this isn't all of
them as a whole this is what we give
each individual one students right now
who are saying I can't go to college
because one I can't afford it and two I
can't afford to be straddled with that
hundred thousand dollars in student loan
debt for the next 40 years of my life so
they don't go meanwhile 35 billion to
Lockheed 26 billion to Boeing in one
single year and you're gonna sit there
and tell me that we can't get universal
health care that we can't get debt-free
college that we can't address the issue
of homelessness that we can't not cut
Social Security and Medicare and
Medicaid and all of these other programs
designed to help American citizens why
because we need to go blow more stuff up
because we need to just show our
military might because Donald Trump
needs a few more floats for his parade
is that what this is about something has
to change
cannot continue on as a country when we
think that it's more important to build
up our arsenal of tanks and planes and
bombs just in case because let's never
forget the United States military is
better funded than any other military on
the planet as a percentage of GDP we pay
more spend more on our military then
most of the rest of the industrialized
world combined not just more but more
combined than most of them we could cut
our military budget almost in half and
still be spending more than any other
country in the world on our military and
yet when it comes to taking care of our
citizens
we're among the last among the
industrialized world